the Vega phacelia was a truly ambitious
undertaking it was envisaged as a
challenger to Porsche and Alfa Romeo in
the late 1950s its young French
manufacturer if I said wanted to enter a
new segment 1959 saw the launch of a new
little Facel called the phacelia the
two-seater sports car was unveiled to
the public at the Paris Motor Show
the phacelia went down well among
well-heeled car drivers with a thousand
units ordered before the year was out
being seen behind the wheel of a
facility much Evoque available as both a
convertible and coupe a the Visalia came
with a specially designed engine a
four-cylinder unit with two overhead
camshafts the 1.6 liter powerplant
delivered about 115 horsepower the
phacelia competed in the mid-range
luxury sports car segment says vintage
car fan beat Loy it was pitted against
the Alfa Giulietta Spyder and Porsche
356 but its price tag put it out of
contention Quinn's fake it ended up
costing almost as much as a Jaguar
e-type on the outside the facility was
clearly related to Faso's larger luxury
models packing a v8 engine but the
designers gave the little speedster
little in the way of the American
styling seen in previous models with or
without a roof it cut a fine figure
the rear had a bold chunky design with
sloped lights
it was flamboyant and glamorous
peristyle otra vez l had already made
itself a name in the industry as a coach
maker for other manufacturers in the
early 1950s explains our vintage
enthusiasts facilty lost body z' for car
makers such as simcha and to a lesser
extent Bentley in 1954 when jean-denis
nose took over at the top they decided
to become a luxury French car
manufacturer from civilization luksus la
vie
the firm's experience paid off the
interior was dominated by lush leather
and carpets though the finish was not
what he'd get from a volume producer
the Facel Vega brand was also known for
its dashboards which looked like they're
made of wood but are actually painted
metal the young car maker planned to
shift up to 2,000 year an ambitious
target but the innovative new engine
proved the downfall of both the model
and its maker a large number of the
engines failed costing Facel dearly in
terms of both warranty repairs and
reputation
the company decided to install a new
superior engine but it was too little
too late
the first engine has been commissioned
from pondan assume that are known for
its gearboxes borrowing from Alfa Romeo
it had two overhead camshafts and ample
revs but more aggressive drivers who
wanted to get the most out of the
four-cylinder unit were often left
stranded with a bust engine and the
switch to a Volvo engine was not enough
to save the phacelia
the fun bit was a cross between
excessive ambition and poor business
partnership in next to no time the car
had a disastrous reputation thanks to
the infamous ancient and that meant the
end for facade salt in the process for
sellers kanika kapoor cannot Facel
replaced 300 engines in the interest of
customer relations relations it would
soon no longer have in 1964 the luxury
French carmaker shut down forever
today the phacelia is a great option for
vintage enthusiasts after an exclusive
classic car for a less than exclusive
price a convertible in good condition
will cost you around thirty five
thousand euros the engines and the later
models as we now know are more reliable
phacelia is ideal if you want a special
car that many people will recognize as
if I sell but not the exact model the
final version the F to be had a decent
engine so there were no more overheating
problems decoding same elephant or
Chevron the phacelia a diva of a car
with a fascinating allure but no
shortage of idiosyncrasies